for the marlins it is eliezer hernandez
fifth start of the season third off the
il coming off a loss against the reds
10 strikeouts in 10 innings and five
earned runs in the two starts since
coming off the injured list
line drive left center victor robles
welcome back to the lineup second plate
appearance of the series his other pinch
hitting was a walk and he's aboard for
escobar
turner in the lineup as well runner goes
swinging a miss throw from alfaro is
right into the runner and got him a
little bit of a tail at the end and diaz
just had to catch it and apply the tag
last night's hero
with a caught stealing to start the ball
game and now escobar a fly ball
into shallow right center field to be
sanchez to make the play and there are
two down
who awaits an o2 pitch
and it's
on the corner for a called strike three
joe west gave him a little room on the
outside
and hernandez works around a couple of
base runners with a caught stealing and
a strikeout
patrick corbin ready to go to work at
the bottom of the first inning the 32
year old left-hander from upstate new
york
a lot of it with the nats only using a
few arms out of the bullpen to go with
the starters
it takes its toll
price you pay for a championship
oh a very uncertain swing by aguilar
must have been looking for something
coming toward him in the fastball
running away
for the first k of the night one ball
two strikes
there's the slider corbin looks at
second and gets the lead runner the
marlins have two on two out for brian
anderson
one ball one strike
and anderson comes through with the base
hit into right field soto's got it here
comes the throw from right
it's late and it's a one-nothing marlins
lead
brian anderson with the rbi
well stay hot b.a you're putting
together great at bats right now here's
alfaro used the middle of the field last
night
marlins have had
already four base runners couple of
walks
fielders choice and of course the rbi
single for ba
and now alfaro puts a charge into one
this one is gone
right center field and a home run for
jorge alfaro
three run shot and the martials are up
four nothing game-winning base hit last
night and what a start to the game
tonight back to the top of the order for
miguel rojas
this is a fly ball out to deep left
field is it going to carry oh yeah it
will another home run for miguel rojas
and again
he gets patrick corbin
marlins extend their lead
got a pitch down and
lashes it into right
two well hit balls by the nets here in
the fourth
fastball and it's ripped by rojas
stopping at second yadiel hernandez and
the nets have doubled their hit total
here
in the miami ball park and that's
cleanly into right field gadiel
hernandez will be held at third
bases loaded three consecutive singles
and he got him on the slider
a huge strikeout for eliezer hernandez
well hernandez needed to be his best
pereiras had some big hits in this
series how about three pitches in a big
strikeout
came over from the cardinals at the
deadline for john lester
this one is popped up
is it going to stay in play alfaro makes
the catch and eliezer hernandez
works out of a bases loaded one out
situation
and protects a six to nothing lead
escobar lifts one out towards center
brinson racing over it'll be whoa look
out
he and de la cruz collide
miggy gets the ball in and now we check
on brinson brinson's got his his eyes on
his uh left hand there yeah brinson's
arm ends up across de la cruz's body
head athletic trainer gene basham out
there
looks like de la cruz is okay that's
good and uh i believe it's that left
thumb that they're looking at with
brinson maybe tough for him to squeeze
the glove closed so he's going to come
out of the ball game here's juan soto
who has walked and bounced to second
juan is due
oh that ball is driven to right center
see
you
later
he finally got something to hit and boy
diddy
nets on the board
soto's 21st and that's one of his
furthest toe runs of the year 4 33 114
on the exit velo and just a different
sound folks two and two with two outs
anderson back behind first that is going
to drop in for a base hit sierra off on
the crack of the bat will score
and anderson drops in another rbi single
7-2
ground ball to miggy one
two
harmon's traded a couple of outs for a
run it's now 7-3
but the bases are clear after the 6-4-3
double play yeah you'll take it
two
and bender strikes him out got him to
chase the slider
works around the two out walk here's the
pitch and here's a ground ball right
side gathered in by aguilar he has it
flips to bass for the out
and he rolls one there's nobody there on
the right side
escobar scores
soto to third
here come the nats it's seven to four
hold on
front door in the breaking ball
aguilard is second
nobody comes nobody covered no
wire never got over soto scores and it's
seven to five all right
2-2 pitch
is hit in the air
right center field long run in for
sanchez and he makes the catch oh boy
all right well uh it's a marlins win
a little bit of a
sweaty ninth inning there hey no wind
nonetheless no doubles at lone depot
park